there's a lot of chemistry and physics
that goes into the sparklers you'll be
waving around on the fourth of July but
the glowing part of the sparkler comes
from just one ingredient a metal powder
that heats until its incandescent and
they burn a crazy hot 1800s to three
thousand degrees there are two reasons
the sparks don't burn when they hit your
skin thermal energy and sighs those
insanely high temperatures aren't a
problem because of the sparks fly
through the air they cool off really
quickly that's thanks to their tiny size
and high surface area the more of the
spark that's exposed to the air the
faster it'll cool off but be careful
with all fireworks and never touch the
burning portion of the sparkler